if you'd like to come on in we're going
to start our second panel take your
seats
good morning we're gonna go ahead and
continue our presentations and are going
to our second panel our second panel
this morning is on the bureaucrat Kings
for those of you that are familiar with
reality TV you might think this is his
latest show in the fall lineup there was
a show called the pin kings at one point
there the desert car Kings which restore
classic cars auction kings which is take
off on Pawn Stars barter kings about
trading items without currency but no
this isn't the relators reality show or
the latest pop culture this is reality
reality politics coming to a theater a
store neighborhood near you indeed
coming into your home every day you may
not be interested in government as the
saying goes but government is interested
in you rather than three branches of
government that legislate execute in
Judah Kate we the main job of government
today is to regulate and there's really
nothing outside of its administrative
reach in purview indeed the greatest
political revolution in the United
States since the established from the
Constitution has been this shift of
power away from lawmaking institutions
to this other thing this regulatory
world that affects our daily lives
what happened how did we get there is
there any hope of getting out we have a
panel today of a lawyer a political
scientist and historian that's the start
of a good joke I think somewhere walk
into a bar and they will speak in this
order first we will hear from Paul
Marino he's the William and Bernice grew
[ __ ] professor of constitutional history
and Dean of Social Sciences at Hillsdale
College he received his BA from the
State University of New York and his MA
and PhD from the University of Maryland
he's held visiting professorships at
Princeton University University of Paris
law school he's the author of several
books the American state from the Civil
War to the New Deal the twilight of
constitutionalism and most recently the
bureaucrat kings the origins
underpinnings of America's bureaucratic
state he'll be followed by Chris
who was a distinguished fellow at Hudson
institution Institute here in Washington
DC he was the president of the American
Enterprise Institute for Public Policy
Research for some time prior to that
he's graduate of Harvard College in the
University of Chicago Law School he
served in the administration's of Ronald
Reagan and Richard Nixon klar at the
Kennedy School of Government and
directed the Harvard faculty project on
regulation and then last we hear from
John Marini who was a senior fellow at
the Claremont Institute and professor of
political science at the University of
nevada-reno he's previously taught at
the University of Dallas and at Ohio
University he is the author of the
politics of budget control Congress the
presidency in the growth of the
administrative state and co-editor of
the progressive revolution in politics
and political science transforming the
American regime dr. Marino will start us
off
thank you Thank You Matthew for that
introduction and I'd like to thank all
the many friends and benefactors who've
made this possible of course Hillsdale
College and dr. Larry Arne the
institutional advancement office and
external affairs at Hillsdale College
and of course for the many donors who
are here who make Hillsdale possible and
for the panelists for coming out for
this discussion of my book this is the
book the bureaucrat kings and if there
is anyone here in the audience from the
fertilizer Association and you read my
book I hope you didn't like it because I
hope it wasn't something familiar that
you want to promote and spread around
the world as dr. Spaulding mentioned I
am a historian but I'm especially
grateful to my colleagues in the
politics department at Hillsdale because
they're the ones who got me thinking
about this topic of the administrative
state because it's only recently that
term the administrative state has become
you know it's not exactly popular at
least moved beyond the confines of sort
of the academic world you hear people
talking about it more today Steve Bannon
talking about the Trump administration
undertaking the deconstruction of the
administrative state so people are
becoming more familiar with what used to
be a term that was sort of a technical
political science term it was sort of
like the term regimes about 20 years ago
right where political scientists
influencing the the Bush
administration's foreign policy that
sort of term of political science began
to enter into the more popular
vocabulary and the administrative state
as a topic in American Constitutional
History my field was something that I
had avoided for a long time because
people still understand and people are
at least in some schools anyway are
taught the Constitution the separation
of powers the structure of the
Constitution and you can read the
Constitution that understand it and
understand the way that the American
political system is supposed to work but
the administrative state is something
that's a lot more technical
complicated sort of baffling and and
and when you get into the scholarship of
the way the government actually works as
opposed to the way that it's supposed to
work it can be somewhat daunting you get
into matters in political theory like
iron triangles and the non delegation
doctrine and and subcommittee government
and it's used against could be rather
off-putting as the late Justice Antonin
Scalia I put it who was something of an
expert in administrative law he said as
only he could say administrative law is
not for sissies I put it off for a long
time because I'm kind of a [ __ ] but I
had to get into it and so a couple years
ago I asked my colleague who was the
host of the last panel or jabish Rideau
who teaches a course in administrative
law at Hillsdale I said all right
RJ if I want to understand this this
topic what's the sort of the go-to book
where's the narrative history about how
this came to be and I discovered that
there wasn't any such book so I set out
to try to write one myself sort of a
coherent and understandable narrative
history of how we got from the founders
Constitution to through the
administrative state a couple of people
have taken this on the great historian
of the 19th century administration a
leonard white wrote several volumes but
he died before he really got into the
20th century where the administrative
state really starts taking hold but his
books are still still worth reading and
he also like most scholars that I think
avoided the important theoretical and
the fundamental issue about the
hostility between the founders
Constitution and the administrative
state which I tried to take attention to
I pay attention to a lot of law
professors today are writing about this
but for the most part they are
apologists of the administrative state
and they're trying to explain that
either there is no incompatibility
between the founders and the
administrative state that the real
founder of the administrative state was
Alexander Hamilton or other founders who
had this in view all the time but then
history served when I went awry or they
make the argument that there was this
administrative state in the 19th century
but nobody noticed it and there it's the
sort of the invisible administrative
state there's lots of work that's been
written about that a very good book
about
a piece of this development in the New
Deal period by georgetown law professor
named dan ernst
it's called toad VLEs nightmare the
administrative state comes to america
but the title is ironic because the
argument of the book is tok Phil's
nightmare didn't work out that way that
the administrative state is here and
it's fine because the architects of it
in the New Deal sort of Americanized it
and judicial eyes it especially so
there's nothing to fear from the
administrative state and often even the
good people I think the people
understand the problem of the
administrative state has focused I think
too much on its procedural debilities
there is sort of arbitrary nature of the
way in which the house sort of how the
administrator Ministry of state operates
rather than what it does and these these
issues are important because procedure
is important they're just to give you an
example of this is my favorite
illustration by Boston University law
professor Lawson who has a textbook in
administrative law he says if you
consider the typical enforcement
activities of a typical federal agency
for example the Federal Trade Commission
you'll get an idea of how the
administrative state works the
Commission promulgates substantive rules
of conduct the Commission then considers
whether to authorize investigations into
whether the Commission's rules have been
violated if the Commission authorizes an
investigation the investigation is
conducted by the Commission which then
reports its findings to the Commission
if the Commission thinks that the
Commission's findings warrant an
enforcement action the Commission issues
a complaint
the Commission's complaint that a
commission rule has been violated is
then prosecuted by the Commission and
adjudicated by the Commission this
Commission do dication can either take
place before the full commission or
before a semi autonomous Commission
administrative law judge if the
Commission chooses to adjudicate before
an administrative law judge rather than
before the Commission and the decision
is adverse to the Commission the
Commission can appeal to the Commission
if the Commission ultimately finds a
violation then and only then the
affected private party can appeal to an
article 3 court but the agency decision
even before the bona fide article 3
tribunal possesses a very strong prison
of correctness on matters of fact and
law this is known as Chevron deference
getting the technical lingo anyway so I
wrote this book to try to explain how
this came about how especially were the
constitutional safeguards that the
founders established to avoid this how
were they evaded separation of powers is
among the most important of them but
others like federalism also enter into
this and I also tried to discuss what I
thought were the intellectual sort of
political theory changes in the 19th
century that brought this about
religious changes changes in American
culture and especially in American
education that brought about a drift
away from the founders political theory
and then ultimately the political ways
in which this was manifested now
fortunate for me when when historians
try to tell their stories they look for
things in current events and in the news
that illustrate the significance of the
of their topics and this usually
provides the material for an
introduction to the book now why this
matters how this affects our your
everyday life and there's certainly no
shortage of material to show this in how
the administrative state is incompatible
with constitutional government and the
way in which what we see before us today
is sort of a realization of what Alexis
de Tocqueville described in democracy in
America the the specter of
administrative despotism if I can just
read to you this famous description by
the Tocqueville of what predicting this
hundred years before before it happened
this is the Tocqueville's nightmare
where America's passion for equality
might produce a new kind of despotism he
prophesied that it would be quote more
extensive and milder and it would
degrade men without tormenting them
modern democracy would produce quote not
tyrants but rather tutors I will call it
administrative despotism for lack of a
better name and some people today call
this the nanny state if the state has to
look out for sort of every aspect of
your life for you the government provide
the vulgar material pleasures that
democratic men seek it would be quote
absolute detailed regular far-sighted
but mild like a parent who wanted to
keep his children from growing up to
remove entirely from them
the trouble to think and the difficulty
of living right this is sort of
Tocqueville vision of what the
administrative state would like and it
would produce a new type of American
character in the last couple of years we
had with the explosion of new regulation
in the Obama administration firstly the
tarp program the Troubled Asset Relief
Program then the dodd-frank act and
especially Obamacare it looked like we
were nearing the completion of the kind
of administrative state that the
Tocqueville described that this was the
the culmination of what Charles Kesler
in his book I am the change about Obama
and modern liberalism describes as a the
fourth wave of administrative government
after the progressives and the new
dealers and the Great Society that Obama
was completing this project of the
construction of the administrative state
and this the jury is still out about
this people who have hopes for the Trump
administration reversing this I think
this is what the the controversy is all
about anyway there's there's still no
shortage of material and down in the
daily news illustrating the pathology of
the administrators state just a couple
of days ago there was a very interesting
piece in the Federalist
September 13th about how the Federal
Motor Carrier Administration regulations
and what they mean for the life of an
independent trucker and if I can just
read the beginning of this he says I
never thought I'd come to a time in my
life when Big Brother would be watching
me 24/7 but then I became a truck driver
every minute of every day is monitored
by Uncle Sam who takes care that I can
never make a decision for myself based
on my circumstances right this is what
it's all about it's about removing the
power that individuals have to make
decisions that affect their own lives
because let's face it I just can't take
that kind of responsibility there's no
way I can decide for myself when I'm
going to sleep or rest or drive after
all I'm just a stupid truck driver what
would I know about such things right
regulators in Washington DC know his
business better better than he does and
this kind of contempt for the ability of
ordinary Americans to manage their lives
I think is what the administrative state
is all about The Economist Jonathan
Gruber write famously said this when
were the planning Obamacare the average
American is just too stupid to realize
what's in his own interest so we had to
kind of trick them in
- the way that Obamacare is going to be
financed unless you own a business when
you hear pundits and politicians drone
on about over-regulation the notion
probably goes in one ear and out the
other but being a truck driver or any
kind of independent businessman it's
similar to owning your own business so
the next time you hear your senator or
favorite radio show a talk show host
decry government regulation and
oversight let me give you an idea of
what over-over regulation looks like on
the ground and literally he describes
the many regulations that truck drivers
I have to deal with on the other hand in
recent news we've had some some good
news coming out about this where the
Trump administrations officials have
been undoing some of the over-regulation
of the last couple of years Betsy DeVos
our new Secretary of Education has
revised the ways that colleges are
supposed to deal with cases of alleged
sexual assault on campus and if you read
what those procedures were they were a
great illustration just sort of no due
process sort of arbitrary ways of
dealing with criminal accusations
summary procedures that were exactly the
kind that the English fought against in
the 17th century in the eventually to
the English Civil War and the Glorious
Revolution a wonderful book about this
by Philip hamburger called is
administrative law unlawful the the
short answer is yes it is it's
incompatible with the American
Constitution and he goes into great
detail about the historical precedents
about this
it's a weighty academic book I tried to
write my book to be sort of more for
ordinary readers so anyway I could say
that before you read hamburgers book you
should read mine my book is sort of
Hamburger Helper
I'm a they use I use the phrase and this
followed this divorce thing about the
campus sexual assault solid a reversal
of earlier administration action in the
Obama administration the rules about the
transgender bathrooms in the schools you
may be familiar with that and the the
thing that this illustrates the best is
that all of this arose from from again
this gets sort of technical title nine
of the amendments to the Civil Rights
Act of 1964 and one of the sort of
landmark pieces of Great Society
legislation and they had to be added to
that because the original title six of
the Civil Rights Act was dealt with
institutions that receive federal aid
prohibited discrimination on race creed
color and national origin but but not
sex and so sex was added to it in title
nine right but all this stuff is about
gender right and if you go back to the
original statute this happens to be
section 16 81 to 88 of what is title 20
of the United States Code you can
actually read the original language of
title 9 and it doesn't contain the word
gender at all right it talks about sex
right and gender is something that's
completely different
yet the bureaucrats and judges who have
supported them indeed the role of the
judiciary in helping in the construction
of the administrative state is a really
important part of the story they've been
able to transform the language of this
statute into something that nobody had
in mind in 1972 when it was it was
written and this is true of affirmative
action in general my first book was
about how you take the Civil Rights Act
in 1964 which says no discrimination on
the basis of race right but Congress did
not define what it meant exactly by
discrimination on the basis of race so
that job was taken over by a new
bureaucratic agency the Equal Employment
Opportunity Commission right and they
decided that no discrimination on the
basis of race means discrimination on
the basis of race that you're going to
be compelled to take race into account
indeed this is the beginning of
Hillsdale College and some other
colleges rejection of financial aid
because of the the counting by race
strings that are attached to this
and again people involved in this law
professors sort of deep in the bowels of
administrative agencies
Alfred Blum Rosen was the guy who was
most responsible for the development of
this new definition of discrimination
that the courts later accepted and this
is the way that the administrative state
works Congress passes a very vague
statute saying that we want a clean
environment or no discrimination or
reasonable railroad rates or whatever
and then it leaves it to the
administrators to define really to make
the law with the substance of what that
law is and then the judges control that
when they think they want to either
confirm or strike down usually they
confirm they're usually said very
deferential about this and some of the
changes that have been made recently
where Congress for example saying that
no big regulation can kick in if it cost
more than a hundred billion dollars a
year or something unless we approve it
right that's good it's an improvement
over the old system but it really
doesn't take us back to the fundamental
point which is that Congress is not
legislating Congress is not doing its
job right it is and deferring it is
delegating to the administrative
agencies the power to make this a law in
the same way as with legislative vetoes
where you know the Congress lets the
president decide whether we're going to
go to war or not and then it's supposed
to through the War Powers Act ratify
that decision that's not the way the
Constitution is supposed to work so I
think the fundamental problem again
going back to the founders Constitution
is restoring the proper behavior of the
legislative body the executive body and
the judicial body so that's what I try
to account for so thank you
[Applause]
coming between Moreno and Marini I
filled my name oughta beat damata or
something like that it's just plain old
German tomb youth a Merinos book which
he has summarized the bureaucrat Kings
is a thorough blow-by-blow account it is
both a political and a intellectual
history going back to the structure and
purposes of the original Constitution to
the first appearances of that uninvited
interloper the administrative
bureaucracy in the 19th century - what
he calls for waves of bureaucratic
growth into the 20th century the
Progressive Era 1900 through 1930 the
New Deal 1930 through 45 the Great
Society and the new social regulation
1945 through 75 and finally partial
deregulation Andry regulation from 75
through 2010 one of the many virtues of
his book is the modesty and
forthrightness of the conclusions and
recommendations that come at the end of
this meticulous history a scholar who
writes a book of big ambition and scope
who devotes years of thought and
research and Luke aberrations when he
gets to the end and has to turn to a
concluding chapter often feels that he
is entitled to tell the world all of his
political ideas which may or may not be
related to what came before so we often
find five legislative proposals three
constitutional amendments a new
political party sweeping proposals
coming at the end very discordant with
what came before Marino has no
we'll have nothing to do with that he
clearly understands the circularity of
many such proposals a passage of his
reminded me of a saying of my old mentor
Edward C Banfield who wrote that most
policy reforms that come from academics
take the form of saying that the
solution to drunkenness is greater
temperance in the consumption of alcohol
he sees this and he concludes first that
nothing is possible without a
reawakening in the public and among our
representatives in Congress to the
principles of the Constitution those
principles rightly understood not as
simply as a regime of dispersed and
contending power but as a mechanism that
tries to use those principles to
operationalize limited government and
classical liberalism second that reform
must begin with the Congress a
realization that it is a body of
enumerated powers that its members job
is deliberative legislation and that it
has to retrieve from the executive
branch that which it has delegated and
third that we need to begin with a
deeper understanding of constitutional
history beginning with widespread
reading of his book itself now you might
think that he's just talking his book
but that a statement of his is the very
last sentence in the book you have to
read a hundred and fifty pages to get to
it and what I understand him to be
saying is that the important
contribution of the scholar is in
analysis and depth of description and
understanding and that the work of
actual reform has to be left to
practical men and women who have
absorbed this scholarship and are in a
position to apply it to changing public
affairs
my own view of the underpinnings of
today's bureaucratic state and the fix
we are in is rather different than
Professor Marino's I do not see a steady
progression from Woodrow Wilson
progressivism to FDR New Deal ISM to the
successions of twists and turns with a
net upward trajectory from LBJ to Obama
and Trump indeed instead I think that
the executive state has had as it has
emerged since about 1970 is
fundamentally different from everything
that came before I do not think the
progressive and New Deal eras were
irrelevant they spawned intellectual
arguments and institutional arrangements
departing from the Constitution's norms
but since 1970 those changes
intellectual and institutional and
constitutional have been put to
radically new and different purposes
which would have been inconceivable to
Woodrow Wilson or Louis Brandeis or
James Landis and his hand have left us
with a bureaucratic state which is much
more intractable than anything that came
before my explanation for this change is
the unprecedented growth over the past
60 years the unprecedented growth and
democratization of income education and
leisure time and the equally dramatic
changes in transportation and
communications and information
technologies altogether the technologies
of human interaction collaboration
surveillance and concerted action
changes in economic welfare and
technology our long-term and continuous
developments I acknowledge they go back
for exactly the century and a half that
is the focus of this book's political
and intellectual histories but they
arrived in they arrived following the
enormous growth in post-world War two
prosperity of the 1950s and 60s at an
entirely new level for the first time
many many millions of American citizens
had the time and inclination to take an
active role in national politics and
policy and they brought to the game many
new interests in issues of health safety
the environment consumerism social
justice personal identity and aspiration
which had not been important parts of
our politics before the new
transportation and communications
technologies from jet travel and
broadcast news in the 1960s to cheap
long-distance communications telephone
telephony in the 1980's to today's
ubiquitous endlessly reticulated
ecosystem of the internet and social
media and smartphones have made it
possible for increasingly numerous and
discrete causes to achieve collective
consciousness and to organize to press
effectively for government intervention
on behalf of a endlessly growing list of
causes
there are antecedents as Professor
Moreno tells us we had a commission in
the 19th century concerned with
steamboats safety on the Mississippi
River the Teddy Roosevelt was an
enthusiastic conservationist we had a
federal agency concerned with food and
drug safety early into the 20th century
but these were not central what was
central in domestic politics was
economic development industrialization
the sharing of the proceeds of
production between owners managers and
employees as late as the New Deal
very few average American citizens were
keenly interested in Environmental
Quality the term barely existed
and if they had been they would have
found it impossible to organize
themselves effectively against the
pressures of for economic recovery which
were the national politics of the day in
which belching smokestacks were a
welcome sign of progress beginning in
the late 1960s these material changes
I've summarized had four big effects one
is that just as in private markets
falling costs of economic organization
and of transactions disrupted as we say
disestablished old hierarchies in
private markets it was IBM and AT&T and
the Big Three automakers that fell by
the boards in politics it was the state
and local political machines the
national political parties that had been
the arbiters of issues and causes and
the disciplining forces of our politics
that were disrupted and in Congress the
seniority system and the system of
autocratic committee chairmen were
essentially abolished certainly greatly
weakened the new politics beginning in
the 1970s was one of atomized rather
than hierarchical politics it was
organized around particular economic and
social issues second Congress as a
result was faced with with unprecedented
pressures for intervention for policy it
was impossible for an institution
designed to be as cumbersome and
slow-moving
as our Congress to cope with all of
these pressures and demands for
intervention and if they came up with
the solution of delegating policymaking
lawmaking to specialized administrative
agencies multiplied without limit EPA
CPSC OSHA nitsa the office for civil
rights the EEOC and many many more third
the agencies were in a good position
technologically to take the
and off they could use new
communications and information
technologies to organize specialized
political coalition's behind the work
that they were doing and they made a
discovery that no one had paid any
attention to since the Administrative
Procedure Act had been passed in 1946
informal rulemaking in I this was a
process by which an agency could simply
announce rules laws that it intended to
implement essentially canvas for memos
have people just send in their thoughts
about what they liked or disliked about
the proposal and then published the
final rule stroke of the pen law of the
land third and fourth Congress then
adopted a new business model rather than
the model of the Constitution lawmaking
through deliberation and collective
choice they turned over the real
lawmaking as Professor Menino has given
us some examples to administrative
agencies and set themselves up as
official lobbyists of this new lawmaking
bureaucratic state that they had created
and by financing their careers their
campaigns re-election and so forth by
championing narrow economic interests
broad ideology ideological causes in the
form of cheering on or opposing whatever
the executive branch is up to now I want
to go back to the progressive and New
Deal eras the Progressive Era came up
with this idea that it would be
effective to combine lawmaking
surveillance enforcement and
adjudication all three things that had
been dispersed in the Constitution in
the hands of neutral expert
administrators the New Deal
forced the courts essentially to abandon
most of the constitutional constraints
that had governed for a century and a
half
especially the commerce power the notion
of the commerce power the idea of
enumerated and limited powers delegation
to administrative agencies and
differential non protection of economic
rights all those things took place in
the 1930s but the effects of both the
progressive and New Deal changes were
much much less profound at the time and
might even have been abandoned or
reversed but for the important material
developments that came later let me give
you a few examples the Progressive Era
was actually much more talk than action
what were the great bureaucratic
achievements the Federal Trade
Commission and the Federal Reserve Board
those were big but they were very very
different than what they came to be
after the 1970s the FTC did not even
have rulemaking power it was simply an
adjudicative body was kind of a Article
two court of some sort the Federal
Reserve Board it but it acquired much
more power after 1970 the Federal
Reserve Board had enormous discretion in
monetary policy but did not have the
regulatory were the immense regulatory
authorities that it is acquired in
recent years the New Deal invented or it
proliferated the idea of the Regulatory
Commission but these Commission's were
in bread and club' they were devoted to
very narrow questions of adjudication
and licensing a big case before the ICC
might be whether a second trucker could
haul artichokes from Castroville
California to Reno Nevada in formal
rulemaking which came later had not even
you candy there's no case law on it it
wasn't even used before in 1970 it
enabled agencies to make policies with
values of
or hundreds of millions of dollars per
year simply by canvassing for comments
and announcing what they wanted to do as
late as the 1970s the doctrine of non
delegation was still alive
the idea of Chevron deference and other
forms of judicial self deference to what
the administrative agencies want to do
these things were still in the future in
1971
progressive Supreme Court Justice
William O Douglas invoked the Schechter
poultry case from the New Deal which
would prohibit a delegation of certain
authorities to the bureaucracy he
invoked it positively to substitute his
own view of what the statute should mean
for that the two agencies wanted to use
and forced the agencies to do that in
order for their work to be
constitutional the demise of these
doctrines non delegation judicial
fidelity to the statutes in confining
the agencies to what they wanted to do
they all fell into the 1980s the result
of immensely complicated new forms of
social regulation where the courts were
presented with impenetrable
controversies under statute that
statutes that had passed Congress by
vast majorities that were highly popular
that were devoted to issues that many
many people cared about
we're holding that the holdings that the
statutes were unconstitutional would
have been far more disruptive and
politically risky to the institution
than anything in the 1930s
I'm sorry okay so I have it I have a
somewhat different view of our current
fix I am less confident that a revival
of popular appreciation of our
constitutional heritage will suffice and
I'm more willing to settle for
incremental improvements I think that
the if we surveyed popular opinion we
would find that 90% of the American
public thinks that the federal
government should police the
introduction of new chemical entities if
they are told that fidelity to the
Constitution means that we have to have
no policing of that or that the decision
on whether a new drug comes to market
should be made by Congress or state
legislators I do not think that the
cause of constitutional revival would be
advanced
I would love to abolish the Education
Department but I am a great fan of
secretary DeVos who Paul has mentioned
taking on particular improvements such
as unwinding these terrible excesses of
the office for civil rights championing
at the national level school choice and
charter schools I would like to amend
the Administrative Procedure Act to make
the cost-benefit test statutory and
reviewable I'd like to see a 15 year
sunset for every rule issued by the
executive branch
I would like any citizen who has a gripe
against the administrative state to be
able to go directly to an article
article 3 court and have his or her
complaint adjudicated the strict
adherent to the original Constitution
will fear that rationalizing the
administrative state in these ways risks
strengthening the administrative state
by making it more productive and more
popular I don't think that Paul would go
all the way but in talking about certain
episodes of regulatory reform there's a
little bit of information
that incremental reforms can actually
hurt the larger causes I'm willing to
take my chances
politics is endlessly contingent and
unpredictable ways lead on to ways and
not always or necessarily to new to new
bad ways the material developments that
I have summarized have in private
markets led to Americans to be extremely
picky customers and have produced huge
improvements in products and services
over the past 20 or 30 years the gap
between what we expect and and get in
private markets and in private society
with the inevitably mediocre products of
government is growing larger and larger
the sheer quantity and busybody nough
sand poor results of government
bureaucracies it seems to me provides
many openings for a political action in
this new world that that I have
described the Democratic Party as
Professor Marino says has become it's
the progress it is become progressive in
the sense of the champion of essentially
everything the bureaucratic state wants
to do maybe a good business model for a
time I think it's very very risky the
Republicans so far have not been highly
effective opponents simply because they
are subject to the same immense
political pressures to go along with
many modern in enthusiasms but I think
that increasingly there are large
opportunities to be taken advantage of
by inspired political leadership to go
much further than we have so far to
reforming the bureaucratic state
[Applause]
Paul Marino has written a wide-ranging
well researched original book on the
rise of the modern bureaucratic
government it's a comprehensive analysis
that incorporates historical political
economic and legal scholarship is
essential to making his case the result
is the bureaucrat Kings the origins and
underpinnings of America's bureaucratic
state in it Marino lays out his
indictment of the American
administrators state and the new ruling
class that has become as chief
beneficiary he writes as a historian but
his most interesting observations are
derived from his views as a citizen
unlike most social scientists he does
not accept the historical inevitability
of what has been called social progress
nor does he recognize change or social
reform as an unqualified good he is
aware of the profound effect that
political change in light he is he
consequently he judges political and
historical and political change in light
of an unchanging standard of the public
good or justice he sees that standard or
the common good as having been
established in the ideas and the moral
perspective inherent in the founding
documents of the regime the Declaration
of Independence and the Constitution he
laments therefore that and I quote from
him the United States is ruled by a
stamp and establishment nowhere
mentioned in the US Constitution once a
federal republic we have become a
centralized bureaucracy run by an
unelected administrative class this
class is consolidated power in
Washington DC and combines the
legislative executive and judicial
functions that the Constitution
separated end quote
he points to Congress as the principal
culprit and justifying the new state he
notes again the Congress has delegated
its law
making power to this bureaucracy and in
doing so makes Congress more powerful
and less accountable moreover he knows
that it has undermine the political
condition is essential to the
maintenance of popular rule the
political separation of powers and
federalism consequently Moreno does not
spare the presidency the courts or the
states as accomplices in the
transformation of a constitutional
regime into a bureaucratic state in
addition he denies the claims of those
who purport to have discovered a hidden
or forgotten administrative Constitution
extending throughout American history as
some administrative law professors now
claim of course no realistic observer
would deny the importance of
administration in all government of any
kind every activity of government
requires some form of execution and
educate an agents with discretion of
some kind to carry out those activities
the necessity of a competent
administration is essential for good
government was well known to the
American founders it's problematic
character in terms of constitutional
government derives from the fact as
Alexander Hamilton observed in
Federalist number 72 now that I quote
the administration of government in its
largest sense comprehends all of the
operations of the body politic whether
their legislative executive or judiciary
and quote the political success of the
Constitution depended upon separating
those power to prevent unified and
despotic rule and to establish a limited
government compatible with political
consent and popular rule consequently
administration was understood as
ministerial and subject to the authority
of each of the political branches all of
which require administration of some
kind consequently administration
understood as a practical activity has
no independent or autonomous authority
granted to it by the constant
the political branches participate in
establishing the ground of
administrating cthe Ora tea in
controlling its effect as well it is
only within the modern concept of the
rational state that administration
acquires a new kind of technical
rational Authority derived from
universal or scientific knowledge which
establishes both its a its autonomy and
assures its status in this regard I
would go further than Marino does in
distinguishing modern bureaucracy from
the older view of administration
understood as Hamilton did in terms of
prudence modern bureaucracy is meant to
be a new form of rule one that
establishes the authority of organized
knowledge and intelligence as the heart
and mind of rational administration Max
Weber perhaps the most profound student
of bureaucracy argued that and I quote
the fate of our times is characterized
by rationalization and
intellectualization and above all the
disenchantment of the world input in his
view the shift from traditional
authority to legal-rational authority
would lead to it I quote again polar
night of icy darkness that with a liquid
where that would culminate in an iron
cage of rational control for weber
unquote for weber modern bureaucracy is
the final form of the metamorphosis of
Reason and its last and only value he
noted and I quote again joined to the
dead machine bureaucratic organization
is at work to erect the shell of that
future bondage to which one day men will
perhaps be forced to submit in impotence
as once the fellows in the ancient
Egyptian state if purely technical good
that is rational bureaucratic
administration and maintenance is the
last and only value which is just to
decide on the manner in which their
affairs are direct input and in his
despair he wondered
what have we to set against this
machinery in order to preserve a remnant
of humanity from this parceling out of
the soul from this from the this
exclusive rule of bureaucratic life its
ideals in quote I do not mean to suggest
that Moreno is sympathetic to
bureaucratic rule on the contrary by
real revealing the theoretical and
political roots of the founders
Constitution he shows them to be wholly
incompatible with what has come to be
understood as bureaucratic or rational
rule in America's Founding period and
throughout its first century and beyond
Moreno shows that administration was
understood in terms of limited
government constitutionalism and
federalism or decentralized
administration popular government
required that the rule of law must must
be established by the people's
representatives and legitimized by the
consent of the government in developing
his argument Moreno gives a brief but
masterful account of the relentless
growth of the administrative state
throughout the 20th century the bulk of
the book deals with the four waves of
the administrative state that paralleled
the political strength transformation
that occurred in the 20th century the
fourth wave has revealed the inability
of the political branches and political
parties to impose limits on
administrative rule Moreno recognizes
that although the separation of power
and I quote from him was designed to
prevent the rise of a centralized
bureaucratic state once that state was
established the same structure made it
difficult to undo
however Moreno denies that the
transformation of the regime was a
product of social and economic change
rather he argues that that that the
change of administrative rule was not in
element or merely the result of
technological change although he does
not deny the reality of social and
economic change he implies a political
choice depends upon public
theory it was marina suggest that I
quote the late 19th century progressives
who chose not to return to our founding
principle but adopt modern continental
European theories of government Moreno
insisted that the political thought of
the American Founding presupposes the
possibility and even the necessity of a
return to first principles he turns to
Lincoln as the guide in making choices
necessitated by political and social
change he notes and I quote again
socio-economic reality changed between
the American Revolution in the Civil War
but Lincoln and the Republicans
persuaded the American people to return
to the principles of founding however by
the end of the 19th century the
influence of German thought had made the
possibility of such a return more
difficult as a result it was thought
that although change required political
choice it was impossible to reject
change
once history had come to be understood
in terms of rational necessity then
rational choice required adaptation or
accommodation of the new and limits
choice to the rejection of a reactionary
past such historicists thought inspired
the programmatic agenda for the politics
of progressivism and twentieth century
liberalism the growth of the
bureaucratic state parallels the rise of
the new social sciences and the
positivist understanding of the law the
authority which justified and
legitimized a modern administrative
state is the technical rational
knowledge derived from the methodology
of the new social sciences
Moreno's judgment concerning the absence
of bureaucratic rule throughout much of
America's past was corroborated by two
of the most prominent observers of
democracy and bureaucracy of the last
two centuries in the 19th century
Tocqueville described the phenomenon of
democratic despotism even more
for the bureaucracy had revealed itself
he called it centralized administration
and he warned democracies must avoid it
if they are to remain free he praised
America for its defence of civil society
institutions and private associations
and the absence of centralized
administrative rule nearly a century
later ludwig von mises still confirmed
polk bills judgment concerning america
in his book bureaucracy published just
before the end of the Second World War
von Mises insisted that only America
could still resist bureaucratic rule he
noted that I quote although the
evolution of bureaucrat ISM has been
very rapid in these last year's
America's still compared with the rest
of the world only superficially
afflicted it shows only a few of the
characteristic features of bureaucratic
management America alone is still free
to choose and the decision of the
American people will determine the
outcome of the whole of mankind end
quote
at mid-century 20th century meesa meesa
still believed that America was governed
politically by those who held offices of
limited power under the authority of a
written constitution he did not think
that America was bureaucratic ruled
because it was not yet ruled by those
whose title to rule was expert knowledge
as he noted that I quote again if
citizens are under the intellectual
hegemony of bureaucratic professionals
society breaks up into two castes the
ruling professionals the Brahmins and
the gullible citizenry then despotism
emerges whatever the wording of the
Constitution and laws may be like
Tocqueville he believed that
bureaucratic rule was a form of
democratic DEC's despotism and like
Tocqueville he believed that America
still had a choice one that may
determine the fate of the whole of
mankind
it was the abandonment of the American
understeer radical perspective of
justice or natural right and a rejection
of its embodiment in the political
science of the Constitution that made
bureaucratic rule possible the
theoretical defense of rational limits
imposed by nature nature's God as a
condition of human happiness was to
become almost indistinguishable from a
political defense of the founders
principles that view required limited
government as a necessary condition of
the defense of Liberty the
administrative straight state requires
unlimited power or rational control of
every human problem however the
long-term success of administrative rule
would require D legitimizing the
principle of the phone the principles of
the founding in the eyes of the people
it would require establishing the
legitimacy of the administrative state
as Marino notes even the defenders of
the administrative state still admit
that state lacks legitimacy the American
people have not consented to it end
quote
nonetheless as Marino has shown the
politics of progressivism have succeeded
in empowering a new class the
bureaucratic kings the bureaucratic
kings drawn from both the public and
private sector whose interest requires
the perpetuation of an administrative
state directed from the center
consequently
the defense of justice or the common
good it's understood in terms of
principles that establish constitutional
government still demanded the defense of
political rule as opposed to rational
rule democracy means self-determination
von Mises noted how can people determine
their own affairs if they are too
indifferent to gain through their own
thinking and an independent judgement on
fundamental political and economic
problems democracy is not a good that
people can enjoy without trouble it is
on the contrary a treasure that must be
daily defended and
concord anew by strenuous effort end
quote
Tocqueville and von mises described an
America still animated by his tradition
of constitutionalism and its defense of
human freedom and failing to failing to
comprehend its animating principles or
by denying the Justice of its own past
it is is it destined to be to succumb to
the fate described by Max Weber the
verdict in America is not yet in that as
long as the people are free to choose
their political leaders and are capable
of not merely participating in elections
but are thereby enable to transform the
political institutions the rule of the
few however well-organized and however
good its intentions remains precarious
it may be the case that is still easier
to enjoy the benefits of rational rule
than to take this trouble of a
reestablishing political rule if so
perhaps as Alexander Solzhenitsyn was
noted only the pitiless crowbar of
events can bring about the kind of
crisis that might reawaken the desire
for freedom and self-government thank
you
thank you for that wonderful panel we
have time for some questions I think
we're going to go directly to that there
are microphones here in the room and if
you would raise a hand I'm sure our
panel will be happy to grapple with your
hard questions thank you
several have you talked about the fact
that our legislators pass very vague
laws and then expect the regulator's to
flesh them out and actually run the
country is that intentional how well if
so has it how long has it been
intentional and if so why I mean why
don't the regulator's skewb the
legislators pass laws that don't require
so much interpretation now I I would say
it's it's it's nothing new and the
important thing about it is is that when
legislators do that they do it in a way
it looks like they're giving away power
and you know Madison in the Federalist
Papers says the Constitution is based on
the idea that the legislature in a
Republican government is apt to absorb
all the powers into its impetuous vortex
and so the founders didn't think the
problem was the legislature giving away
problem of giving away power they
thought it was a grand izing power so
this looks like they're acting in self
ad negating way but they're not because
they're saying making the hard policy
choices right that's difficult lawmaking
is hard and it's politically risky so
let these guys do it and then when they
make the rules in such a way that it
harms my constituents then I intervene
as a sort of an arms would arms woodsman
and that doesn't help my chances get
reelected so I think that's the way that
the new system works it's actually
Congress increasing its power by letting
somebody else make these hard choices I
think the first of these was the
Interstate Commerce Act where if you
look at the railroad industry in the
late 19th century you had sort of
conflicting policy
contraints railroads had monopoly powers
and some lines and there was too much
competition in others and you couldn't
get any reconciliation of the
conflicting interests so the Interstate
Commerce Commission was the first of
these independent regulatory agencies
that was given the power to make those
choices
it took a long time though because the
courts at the time kept the first this
first agency on a very short leash
because they looked upon them as
competitors and a lot of what the
progressives were trying to do was
establish a these regulatory agencies as
alternatives to the regular courts and
the way in which the courts manage that
is very interesting part of the story I
think Chris is right about the
bureaucratic state as we know it really
didn't arise in a fundamental way until
the seventies and what I think what
changed was so much of political
activity was conducted at state and
local government levels before the 1960s
and seventy-ninth at there was a
decentralized kind of administrative
structure and Congress itself defended
state autonomy until about 1965 until it
then began to think that the only way
that we can compete with the executive
is to is to centralized administrative
power but when you make laws on great
detailed things you can't make general
laws you have to delegate that power to
specialized bodies you're trying in
other words in trying to do so much that
used to be done either at state local
government level of government or in
civil society institutions remember you
had a whole private second that that is
increasingly being changed in this
period so it becomes impossible to pass
general laws in that way and I think
Paul is right that than to that once
they learned how to delegate authority
and profit from it by establishing ways
in which they could remain
in their offices by nonpartisan
non-political activity Ombudsman like
activity etc it becomes much harder
I agree with what Paul and John have
said I would I would add two points one
is that passing very very generally
worded statutes that essentially
establish realities as law I just kind
of good things that we all agree for
agree with in and leaving the discretion
to the agencies was was in order to deal
with this vast quantity of pressures for
doing things so all the federal
government's in charge of hiring and
firing handicapped people
I never occurred to me that the federal
government should do that but you know
now that people come in and talk to me
yes you know we should be in favor of of
that but there are a lot of complicated
questions there we don't have time for
it
so we're just gonna set up an agency and
let them handle it next I mean you can
you can make a lot of law that way I
secondly there was a there was another
pro-growth in part to this the old New
Deal agencies they were kind of
balancing they weren't missionary
agencies they were just they were mainly
cartels actually the new agencies were
missionary and I do believe that there
was a strong pro-government pro-growth
progressive in the modern sense of the
term animus behind passing vague
statutes because what they were doing is
they were taking a general proposition
that everybody would agree with but they
were setting up a missionary agency
devoted to it and they knew that that
would lead to a much more activist
interventionist government than they
would be able to get through a vote of
majorities of the House and the Senate
so I think that there were these other
factors operating as well
my name is Bruce Hamilton I'm from
Dallas question for mr. Tim youth
I appreciate your thesis as I understand
it that technology specifically
communications and transportation have
driven opportunities for more and more
narrow factions which drove the
centralization of power the thing that I
didn't address was structural changes
and I'm specifically thinking about the
16th and 17th amendments which allowed
the popular election of senators and the
federal income tax which drove the or
averted the gaze of the average citizen
away from the Statehouse and to
Washington I'd like to have your opinion
on those kinds of structural things
changes well I I I think they've been
important and the nationalization of a
political organization and discourse
goes back it goes back a long way and we
and I think that these antecedents are
important my what I would say about the
impact of technology on this is that it
has made Madison's extended Republic
small so when we talk about problems we
we can all connect with each other we
can put together coalition's that are
for this and that that we have set in
place earlier in the 20th century
institutions like a national
unapportioned tax a popular election of
senators has has sort of set the table
for a huge nationalization of political
discourse but I think that other
developments since then have enabled
these ideas that were there before to
achieve things in governmental growth
suppression of the initiative and
sovereignty of states
and and other unhappy developments how
about right let's mine right here in the
middle sorry
in the opinion of the panel there are
other countries that do it better at
least to a limited extent other lessons
we can draw from abroad I'd say you know
if you look at health care there'd be
some better examples over the United
States spend something like close to 20
percent of our GDP on health care
because of the clumsy sort of
incremental but ways in which our system
of employer finance the health care has
arisen and a lot of people again even
conservatives and sort of libertarians
and say we'd be better off if we had a
single-payer system because it would
just be more efficient than all of the
bureaucratic waste that's that's built
into this so the kind of accidental
incremental way in which our welfare
state is developed I think has made
other countries yeah do it do it better
I think that to the the decline of the
representative legislature and the
assumption of many many governing powers
that did not belong to the executive
since before the cut before the US
Constitution is a universal phenomenon
and I think I could give we could give
approximately the same talks about
developments in the European Union and
so forth I think that I think that other
states have a better have a better mix
and in in in Denmark they have a very
generous safety net but the employment
relationship is much more governed by
private contract people have it is a
less regulated nation it's a nation of
six million people it's highly
homogeneous and it's I think it's very
difficult to draw lessons from such a
society for for a vast highly
heterogeneous extended nation such as
ours
yeah I think it depends what you want
rule to be whether you want people to
participate in their own rule or whether
you want rational rule I mean Brussels
in the European Union you have a
relatively expert rational rule but now
you see the dissatisfaction of the
people in those countries because they
don't have political participation in in
that kind of rule so I think it's a
question of whether or not you want
human freedom where human individuals
are free to pursue the kinds of
activities that they can pursue in other
ways other than political and
governmental that would require
reestablishing some kind of ground for a
civil society that I think is has
disappeared you have a kind of
politicization of everything of course
technology makes it much simpler but it
also makes it harder to establish any
kind of common good any kind of any
notion of a particular fate of a
particular people and so even the notion
of a country becomes difficult to
sustain in our time it's a radical
Trump's were running to try to establish
a concept of American citizenship where
the common good is the country itself
that's like the last common good among
America if you that should be the first
common good it in a normal social
compact situation but it's a question of
what you want I'm a de choice between
you get either rational rule or
political maybe we want rational in
which case then you don't have political
I think with that we're gonna have to
stay on our schedule and conclude this
panel and we are going to move in to
lunch which is directly in the hallway
are the Ballroom around through the
hallway thank you very much thank you
panic